we start with a developing story in
north las vegas tonight seven dogs are
dead after a house fire and
investigators believe this blaze was set
intentionally fire crews first called to
the home near kerry and las vegas
boulevard just after five o'clock this
evening and that's where we find sasha
loftis tonight for more on what is a
tragic incident
denise and brian there is still quite a
bit of damage here behind me at this
home in north las vegas now as you
mentioned we are told this fire was
intentionally set we actually saw crews
out here boarding up these windows and
kind of finishing tidying up this scene
just a few minutes ago this happened
around 5 p.m as you can see from this
video taken by a neighbor the fire
started in the garage and spread to the
backyard the three people who were home
when this happened are all ok but north
las vegas fire says seven dogs died in
the blaze investigators have ruled this
as arson and damages are estimated at
about 250 thousand dollars at this point
this was a one alarm fire call meaning
firefighters were able to get in under
control pretty quickly but as i
mentioned you can see here that charred
wall quite a bit of damage left over at
this home here now this is a developing
story so of course stay with eight news
now for the very latest both on air and
online reporting live tonight sasha
loftis 8 news now